we have a clip here I want a minute
should we get to where this is early on
in your relationship very early on and
Kumail is trying to convince you to
watch a Vincent Price movie yes that's
almost like maybe it's his move and it's
a really funny part of the movie because
it's a guy sort of trying to introduce a
woman he's interested in to something
thinking she doesn't know anything about
it yeah but I do find that that is as a
nerd girl growing up in nerd girl dating
nerd guys they're always like trying to
like welcome to my world of pop culture
and oh I can show you the sites and what
kind of stuff we're guys trying to like
introduce you to all things that they
would think that somehow I didn't know
about like mr. show kids in the hall
Conan for example and I'd be like what
do you what are you doing like that's
why we're dating is because we both like
the same stuff but this was this is
ripped from the headlines as you would
say for law and order this scene from
the movie is kind of a direct directly
taken from our one of our first dates
let's take a look at this early
recreation of a date from the big sink
okay
the year is 1969 MGM has at a string of
failures so it turns to its most
bankable star Vincent Price is this your
compatibility test
I think the way some people are with
Vonnegut or bass no just watch the movie
and take it serious do kiss are you
serious I love it when men test me on my
taste I just want to share this movie
with you so I don't know why you're
reading into many women have you showed
this movie to zero how many women have
you shown a B horror movie to on like a
third date
what's interesting about that theme
Kemal wrote the first version about the
first draft and a senator Emily and it's
a scene where I show her this movie and
Emily is delighted and stunned and then
I got the rewrite back from Emily and I
was a cow this is a very different take
on what happened now was it weird for
you because the actress playing you has
make-out scenes with Kumail who plays
himself yeah conveniently and I'm just
curious was that you were you on set for
those and how did it feel I I was on set
every single day but at kumail's request
I was not on set for the makeout scenes
and both Emily and Zoey were like why
it's not so weird however here oh you're
being so weird and I'm like so you want
me to make up with someone else while I
call her by your name and you give me
notes and I'm the weird one
sure yeah but you are never gonna make
it on pornhub you're just
people think that make-out scenes and
movies are like sexy too though they're
awful they're really awful I happened to
be on set when one of them was being
filmed and I was so happy that I wasn't
on set for the rest of them because I
was behind the monitors and as they were
making out literally everyone's like
turning and watching me and I kept being
like I was like why am i giving a
thumbs-up yeah I'm a creepy emoji
you